Even though it was the day before the meeting, I misunderstood and was
alone for an hour
.
It seems like it was a circumstance, so you rushed over
This is
a coincidence, isn't it amazing?
[Music]
Agiri
Hayashi's partner's adjustment
Originally, I'm not that weak in alcohol, but
it's been a long time since I've had a drink with someone, so I've become loose and I've
caused a lot of trouble.
No matter what Koiwai-san says to
me, I'll try not to get involved anymore.
I was able to talk a lot.
Actually, I was
quite happy about that.
I like dd, so
I was happy
about that.
Music]
I know Sakurai shouldn't listen to it, but I'm happy to buy
[music]
5 people
Morioka-san